[Musica]
d
perché ci ammaliamo perché perdiamo la
salute
pensateci un attimo i motivi sono molto
semplici e vicini a tutti noi il primo
banale perché invecchiamo ci ammaliamo
perché viviamo in un ambiente inquinato
che ci dà fastidio ci ammaliamo per il
caso la sfiga se volete succedono delle
cose ci ammaliamo perché i sistemi
sanitari ogni tanto sbagliano e ci danno
un problema ci ammaliamo per ragioni
legate alla nostra genetica o la nostra
e epigenetica che ha una cosa un po più
complicata e infine ci ammaliamo a causa
dei nostri stili di vita
la letteratura esistente ormai in modo
unanime dice che questo ultimo motivo è
quello più importante e soprattutto è
quello in cui noi ci possiamo fare
qualcosa di più
cosa significa stili di vita cosa
mangiamo se fumiamo no se beviamo
se facciamo attività fisica e se siamo
stressati ora esiste una parola
longevità che è fatta da due componenti
quanti anni viviamo e quanti anni in
salute
viviamo e qui c'è una notizia buona e
una notizia cattiva quella buona è che
ogni anno che passa la nostra vita si
allunga di due mesi e mezzo da tanti
anni poi ce n'è una cattiva che gli anni
in salute invece si sono bloccati e in
alcuni paesi stanno tornando indietro
quindi il numero di anni di vita che
viviamo non in salute si sta allargando
di fatto se volete
e se vogliamo semplificare se vogliamo
farci del male quello che succede è che
fino a 50 anni possiamo fare un po
quello che ci pare e la nostra vita non
cambia di tanto poi quello che abbiamo
fatto da 0 a 50 anni presenta il conto e
arrivano dei demoni delle cose chiamate
malattie cardiovascolari cancro malattie
psichiatriche o mentali o malattie
respiratorie e questi demoni tagliano la
qualità della nostra vita
bene quello che vi sto descrivendo è uno
dei diversi
esempi di meccanismi sociali in cui
succede questo le azioni che voi fate
oggi hanno un effetto molto lontano nel
tempo e hanno un effetto indiretto
non così chiaro da capire ci sono altri
fenomeni sociali appunto che hanno
questa caratteristica pensate al debito
pubblico
lo facciamo oggi lo ripagheremo per
tanto tempo pensate all'educazione
studiamo oggi e gli effetti dei nostri
studi si vedranno dopo tanto tempo
pensate al co lead i comportamenti che
abbiamo oggi si vedranno tra settimane
mesi quindi tutti questi fenomeni sono
in fondo legati allo stesso meccanismo
mentale
vi faccio due esempi dalla storia della
medicina e due esempi nella nostra nella
nostra vita normale il primo esempio
accade nel 1846 dottor morton a boston
scopre come addormentare i pazienti
prima di fare la chirurgia scrive un
articolo in poco tempo poche settimane
in tutto il mondo tutti i chirurghi
usano queste metodologie per far
addormentare i pazienti perché perché
ovviamente la distanza tra l'azione e
l'effetto è immediato e la facilità con
la quale un chirurgo può lavorare a quel
punto è massima rispetto a prima dove il
paziente era sveglio
secondo esempio l'anno dopo vienna il
dottor semmelweis si rende conto che i
medici andavano a lavorare sulle
puerpere con le mani sporche e questo
produceva tantissime donne morte lo dice
bene ci sono volute decine e decine di
anni prima che i medici nel mondo
capissero che dovesse dovevano lavorare
lavarsi le mani
due esempi nella vostra vita a cui
probabilmente non pensate più di tanto
di fenomeni rilevanti per quello che
stiamo raccontando il primo è lavarsi i
denti fino al 1950 erano pochissime le
persone che si lavano i denti oggi penso
che tutte le persone qui presenti un
paio di volte al giorno si lavano i
denti sono
qualche minuto al giorno che dedichiamo
a stare in salute
il secondo esempio in italia ci sono 20
milioni di persone che in un modo o
nell'altro fanno sport fanno attività
fisica quindi in un modo nell'alto
dedicano una parte del proprio tempo a
stare in salute
ok ora il problema fondamentale è come
si fa a far diventare cool a far
diventare figo occuparsi della propria
salute
dedicando un po di tempo ogni giorno e
dovete immaginare che sopra le spalle di
ognuno di noi ci sono sempre un diavolo
è un angelo il diavolo vi dice sì ma se
io non posso mangiare quello che voglio
fumare non posso fare la vita che voglio
che senso ha questa vita falla e
l'angelo che vi dicessi mai un piccolo
investimento che devi fare tutti i
giorni che ti permetterà di vivere
meglio
ora il problema che tutti noi abbiamo è
che quasi sempre vince il diavolo quasi
sempre vince il diavolo quindi il
problema che abbiamo è come facciamo a
sconfiggere quel diavolo
quali sono le tecniche quali sono le
idee che ci permettono di portare le
persone a dedicare un po di tempo ogni
giorno a stare in salute
ce ne sono alcune di queste idee per
esempio in questi anni si sta provando
ad usare una figura professionale che si
chiama coach della salute è
semplicemente una persona che aiuta le
persone a capire come concretamente
stare in salute giorno per giorno
telefonandogli mandando gli sms oppure
l'altra cosa che si è capito è che le
gli stili di vita sono un fenomeno
sociale
banalmente i figli di famiglie obese
tendono a essere obesi persone che
vivono in un ambiente che crea l'obesità
tendono a essere obesi quindi non puoi
lavorare sul singolo se non lavori sulla
comunità
la terza tecnica che si è scoperta è
lavorare sui costi delle azioni e sui
tempi con cui diamo dei feedback
diciamo la persona che la sua azione sta
funzionando ok quindi tutti questi stili
di vita che vi ho raccontato alla fine
afferiscono a un solo meccanismo mentale
che è quello della volontà se sappiamo
se siamo in grado di toccare questo
meccanismo farlo funzionare
abbiamo trovato la medicina più
importante che c'è oggi nel mondo molto
più importante di qualsiasi pillola voi
possiate prendere quindi se sapremo
insegnare alle persone se sapremo
aiutare le persone a mangiare bene a
nostre sarsi a non fumare e bere bene e
poco ea fare attività fisica
avremmo migliorato i sistemi sanitari e
la salute di tutti
in tutto il mondo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]